so now
you're you're in this space with the
nets
and you know everybody has made this big
deal about kyrie and
you know his beliefs and
him missing games and just like we all
do he got his [ __ ] yeah and a lot of
people are now saying that is what's
going to cost y'all
ultimately of reaching where y'all want
to reach what do you make of that i mean
i just think people don't like kyrie
because he wanted to leave cleveland and
he wanted to leave boston i don't think
he's any deeper than that
he doesn't harm anyone he hasn't said
anything that's disrespectful to anybody
his game is beautiful to watch i just
think people don't like the decisions on
what he chooses to play
and they sort of amplify everything
because everybody in this league has
their [ __ ] they may say something
over a course of six months that may
everybody may not agree with that's just
nature our business you know when you're
that good at what you do
everything is lower amplified and
sometimes it's a little extra you know
so what kyrie does especially in our
building nobody is making a big deal out
of it just like a lot of [ __ ] we did in
our building we didn't give a [ __ ] if
clay missed practice right
who can like long you're there for the
game as long as you you know you healthy
enough to play like you give a [ __ ] like
when you you and coach cursed each other
out literally as soon as the practice
was over it was cool like you know so it
was like everybody's mature enough to
understand like we come to work we
handle our business and you be who you
are